and i've had an obstacle that i then  figured out it gave me that like  validation within myself that for so  many years i was searching for outside  of myself i was searching for my husband  to come home every day and validate me  because i made nice dinner right i was  waiting for validation for my parents to  tell me i was a good wife i was waiting  for validation from so many  external people or things that having  that pivot putting myself in these  situations where i didn't think i was  capable and then going oh my god i'm  actually capable to figure it out  gave me that idea of what else am i  capable of  and that was the thing of i don't know  what i'm capable of i don't know where  i'm going but the idea that who i am  today does not dictate who i can be  tomorrow was so intoxicating  that i was like i need to do more of  this and that's where i started to pivot  and say what life do i actually want and  by golly i'm gonna freaking demand it of  myself